Speaker 1: Joe Biden is apparently
apparently standing firm and saying,
No Donald Trump. I am not going to exert executive
privilege over documents that you don't want,
made public or made available to investigators
because they relate to your possible wrongdoing
leading up to and on January six, 2021, the day
of the Trump riots. This is again what Joe Biden.
We'll see if he stands firm indefinitely. But for
now, Joe Biden is saying no. CNN was the first to
report the Biden White House is again rejecting
more executive privilege. Claims by Donald Trump,
reported on by Kaitlan Collins and Paul LeBlanc,
or LeBlanc could be either. President Joe Biden
has once again refused to assert executive
privilege over more documents that former
President Donald Trump has sought to keep out of
the hands of the committee investigating the Jan.
six attack on the U.S. Capitol, according to a
letter obtained by CNN. White House counsel Dana
Remus informed national archivist David Ferriero
on Monday that Biden would not assert privilege
over additional materials that Trump requested
remains secret as a matter of executive privilege.
Trump is going bonkers trying to keep
this stuff private, as the article says.
Trump already filed a lawsuit to stop
the National Archives, the custodian
of his administration's White House records, from
giving documents to Congress that he believes
are privileged, and the latest documents will
likely become part of the lawsuit. The National
Archives is set to begin turning over records
to the House on November 12 unless Trump gets a
court order. That's a couple of weeks from now.
Remus wrote President Biden has considered the
former president's assertion and I have engaged
in consultations with the Office of Legal Counsel
at the Department of Justice. President Biden
has determined that an assertion of executive
privilege is not in the best interests of the
United States and thus therefore is not justified
as to the documents provided to the White House
on September 16 and September 23. Accordingly,
President Biden does not uphold the former
president's assertion of executive privilege.
This is sort of like trying to use your employee
discount after you no longer work at the company.
It's just not up to Trump at this point in time.
And Trump really, really doesn't like that.
He wants it to be up to him. He wants to
be able to shield these documents. Now,
a couple of important notes. One. This has sort of
been like par for the course with Trump. Is this
how an innocent person behaves? Is this how an
innocent person behaves? That's a regular question
we've asked with the former Trump administration
number two executive privilege and classified are
not the same thing. There are people who either
out of ignorance or out of bad faith are saying,
Why won't Biden keep these things classified
as they should be? It's irresponsible for
Biden to declassify. No, no, no, no, no. It
was Trump who spilled classified information
to a Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office.
Remember that? What were you saying at the time,
sir or ma'am and privileged and classified are
two different things. Executive privilege is
there to make sure that things can be openly
discussed by members of an administration
with a degree of confidentiality, because
sometimes if everything that's discussed
is public, it affects your ability to have a
functioning government. That's not the same thing
as this is just classified information. And can
there be executive privilege asserted over things
that were classified or not? Of course, you can
have overlap between these two groups. Imagine a
Venn diagram. Executive privilege classified. OK,
we are not talking about here as far as we know,
we are not talking about classified information.
So cut it OK, either you're wrong or you're
just trying to fool us with your bad
faith argumentation. But it's neither.
Joe Biden needs to hold steady on this. If Trump
claims he did nothing wrong, there should be
nothing to hide. Just carry on. That's it. Trump
has no say here now on the tail end of this.
Could some I would never recommend this. Never.
You guys know me, I would never recommend this,
but sometimes documents leak. Here we're
talking about Trump wanting to prevent
these documents from getting in the hands of
the committee investigating the Jan. six riots.
That's what we're talking about right now,
not about them getting out to the public.
Sometimes things leak, and if they did, it would
be very interesting. I'm not suggesting anyone
leak anything, but sometimes that happens
and it really triggers Donald Trump. Now,
last thought on this? Consider this really funny
contrast to his supporters. Donald Trump insists
I didn't do anything wrong, and I am under
no obligation to give anything to these witch
hunt people. These are witch hunts, and they're
just trying to go after your favorite president.
I have all the power. They can't take it
from me. I don't have to give them anything.
Meanwhile, he's privately going to Joe Biden
saying, Please don't release the documents.
Speaker 2: Joe, please
Speaker 1: don't release the documents.
That's your Big Alpha, Donald Trump that these
people pray at the altar of just a contrast to
keep in mind. Do you think here's my my question
do you think Joe Biden will hold steady on this
and not assert executive privilege as requested
by Donald Trump? I'm optimistic that he will.
Let me know your thoughts. You can find me
on Twitter at Packman. We'll be right back.